the political world is still trying to
understand why Fox would fire its
highest rated host the highest rated
host in the history of cable news at the
height of his powers
several theories are swirling some have
said it's because of a recent defamation
lawsuit related to the 2020 election but
that theory Falls flat when you remember
that plenty of other Fox hosts went way
further than Tucker on Election fraud
claims and they still have their jobs
another theory is that Tucker just chose
to leave
that one Falls flat when you remember
that he signed off his Friday show
telling viewers that he'd be back on
Monday now
Vanity Fair as a third Theory
the theory is that Tucker was fired for
a speech he gave at the Heritage
Foundation over the weekend
maybe we should all take just like 10
minutes a day to say a prayer about it
I'm serious like why not and I'm saying
that to you not as some kind of
evangelist I'm literally saying that to
you as an Episcopalian the Samaritans of
our time
I'm coming to you from the most humble
and lowly theological position you can
I'm literally an Episcopalian okay
and even I have concluded it might be
worth taking just 10 minutes out of your
busy schedule to say a prayer for the
future and I hope you will
the whole speech was excellent I was not
able to attend that dinner because I was
already booked to speak at another
conservative gathering in Colorado that
night I do wish I could have made it to
the dinner though it turns out that
Heritage Foundation dinner might have
been one of the most consequential in
the history of conservative media
according to Vanity Fair the head honcho
over at News Corp didn't like Tucker's
religious recommendation a fox Source
reportedly told Vanity Fair quote that
stuff freaks Rupert out
I don't know what really motivated Fox
to fire Tucker of all the theories out
there this one is the most absurd
Episcopalian extremism
the jokes write themselves that's the
joke that Tucker made
as he gave his advice it's the craziest
motive you could think of
which is why it's also the most
convincing in this Fallen World
you can call for the slaughter of babies
the castration of children the wholesale
denial of Truth and you will be
celebrated as a wise man and a hero you
will be rewarded
but gently suggest that people humble
themselves and pray to God
the principalities and powers and
spiritual wickedness in high places that
you might have heard about the prince of
this world they don't like that so much
that's the sort of thing that can get
you taken off the air
and that's the sort of thing that proves
Tucker's point I'm Michael Knowles it's
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show a really
rousing beautiful speech speaking of
speeches from a man who ran as a woman
in the London Marathon talked about girl
power we'll get to that in just a second
first though on the Tucker cancellation
that has rocked the media and political
worlds
at least one person is celebrating I
think a lot of the left is celebrating
right now but but one leftist figure in
particular AOC could not be happier
Tucker Carlson is out at Fox News
couldn't have happened to a better guy
um
what I will say though is
while I'm very glad that the person that
is arguably responsible for the
some of the largest driving some of the
most uh amounts of death threats and
violent threats not just to my office
but to plenty of people across the
country
I also kind of feel like
like waiting for the cut scene at the
end of a Marvel movie after all the
credits have rolled and then you see
like the villains like hand
re-emerge out to glip grip over like the
end of a building or something
but
deep platforming works and it is
important and um
there you go good things can happen
so blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah D platforming works
that's her thesis
and
putting all the blah blah blahs aside
and you just get to the central thesis
of her argument
she's right
d-platforming does work
the left knows that that's why the left
D platforms people and severely hampers
their ability to communicate
and to the right
some people on the right know that but
some people on the right engage in
magical thinking where they believe well
the more you suppress me the more you
censor me the more people will talk
about me it'll have an ironic it'll have
a paradoxical effect where actually if
you try to suppress my speech it'll just
go everywhere that isn't true
think of the major figures who were
kicked off of social media
they just kind of went away
big people in the media
de-platformed they just kind of went
away they were they may have maintained
a small power base but their reach was
greatly diminished this is true even of
Donald Trump
Donald Trump every thought that passed
through his head he would tweet out and
it dominated the news cycle for years
and years and years
then they booted him off of social media
and even Trump who had been a celebrity
for 40 years he had been the president
of the United States he
diminished he faded in the National
conversation
some people still talked about his
press releases and his
truth social posts but nowhere near the
kind of press coverage that you saw at
the height of his powers de-platforming
works
and conservatives should should embrace
that not the arbitrary or unjust kind of
D platforming that the libs push where
you say oh he said a true thing we got
to shut him up oh he said men aren't
really women we oh we gotta we gotta
censor that guy oh he said babies
are actually human beings oh we got to
shut him up we gotta stop him from
saying that no
but we do support some kind of D
platform we want we want to de-platform
drag queens in the elementary school
don't we okay so there we go we're
admitting the Deep platforming works
we want to de-platform the leftists who
are making direct threats against
conservatives don't we okay D
platforming works we want to de-platform
Maya kababi the author of gender queer
which is gay porn in the libraries for
kids yeah okay D platforming work you're
right it does work aoc's got a point
now in the case of Tucker Carlson is
Tucker totally done no I hope I hope
he's got plenty of other outlets that
would be more than happy to platform him
I know daily wire certainly would
Jeremy pointed out uh when when Tucker
got the can at uh Fox he said listen I
assume Tucker's already got his own
plans but we are willing to break out a
comically sized uh cardboard Shack you
know if he's willing to come on over
here
but but D platforming certainly works
now speaking of comically large checks
when you want to streamline your
finances you've got to check out ramp
right now go to ramp.com Knowles do you
want a better way to simplify your
business finances across expenses vendor
payments and accounting if so ramp could
be a complete game changer for your
business ramp is a corporate card and
expense management software designed to
help you save time and money with ramp
you can issue cards to every employee
with limits and restrictions and
automate expense reporting so you can
stop wasting time at the end of every
month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to the time you'll
save each month on employee expenses
will allow you to close your books eight
times faster businesses that use Ram
save an average of three and a half
percent within the first year ramp is
easy to use get started in less than 15
minutes whether you have five employees
or five thousand right now you can get
200 fifty dollars off when you join ramp
go to ramp.com
Knowles cards issued by Sutton Bank and
Celtic Bank members FDIC terms and
conditions apply
speaking of d platforming
a widow named Jessica Bates wants to
adopt children out of the foster care
system
she lives in the state of Oregon
she can't do it
she can't do it why
because
she's Christian
Jessica Bates was widowed some six years
ago in a car accident
she was already months into the adoption
process when she noticed an emphasis on
supporting
lgbtism the LGBT movement
specifically respecting accepting and
supporting the sexual orientation or
gender identity of any child placed into
her home
so she could get a little boy to take in
and care for out of the foster care
system and then one day the boy says I'm
actually a little girl and the Foster
the adoption system says you have to
treat the little boy as a little girl
she says well I can't do that that would
be a lie it's just not true and it's
certainly out of line with my Christian
beliefs
and so
the foster care system says okay well
you can't have a kid
you can't adopt a kid
the thrupple the gay throuple three
dudes that we talked about on the show
last week
they can adopt a child no problem
but this lovely Christian Widow is not
allowed to adopt a child out of the
foster care system not even a newborn
child newborn children are harder to
adopt she can't even take in a poor kid
out of the foster care system because
she's Christian according to the system
it would be child abuse if she took in
that that kid the gayth ruffle takes in
a kid that's wonderful that's so
beautiful that should get headlines all
over the world but a Christian woman
takes in a kid now that's child abuse
and it has to be one or the other
it ha the answer to this problem is not
tolerance the answer to this problem is
not diversity the answer to this problem
is not wow can you believe how crazy the
foster care system is yeah it is crazy
but think about it from their
perspective
the foster care system believes and the
foster care system in this case just
being an arm of the state representing
the crazy ideas that have recently been
enshrined in our law they they view the
situation as
some men are born in the bodies of women
some women are born in the bodies of men
there is no higher moral calling than to
do whatever feels good sensually and
physically
and so if you are a you think you're a
woman but you're in the physical form of
a man
you need to have access to cross-ex
hormones you need to have the ability to
chop off your genitals you need to wear
stilettos in a dress you need to be
called she and her you need to otherwise
you'll contradict your true self you'll
become anxious you'll become depressed
you'll become suicidal it would it would
be child abuse for a trans kid to be
raised in a Christian home that's what
they believe that's the idea enshrined
in our law certainly in Oregon but in a
lot of places around the country frankly
even at the federal level because of
those two stupid Supreme Court decisions
in 2020. Bostock and the Harris Funeral
Homes case which enshrined the idea of
transgenderism in the federal law until
we can undo it once we get enough
conservative judges and enough political
momentum
that's probably not going to happen
anytime soon might have to wait a little
while as we had to wait with Roe v Wade
but we can build toward that
and we have to do that because the
consequence of enshrining that into law
is that Christian women are not allowed
to adopt kids but gayth Rebels are
it has to be that way
or conversely if boys can't really be
girls and if sexually confused little
boys and girls should not be pumped full
of poison and have their genitals
chopped off
and if the science shows the largest
data set on this shows that actually the
transgender procedures Surgical and
hormonal do not alleviate depression and
anxiety and suicidality and all the
other conditions associated with
transgender ideology if actually at
least in one case in the case of anxiety
they make the condition worse
well then that would be child abuse in
in in that world if all of that stuff is
true which it obviously is then to raise
a child and raise a little boy and
pretend he's a little girl that's child
abuse and that person should not be
allowed to adopt children and the gay
throuple with all the crazy sexual ideas
and anthropological ideas that Trio
should not be allowed to adopt kids but
it has to be one or the other because
the state has a legitimate interest in
preventing child abuse and so therefore
the state has to form ideas on what
child abuse is so what's child abuse
raising a kid to believe in God and
believe in all the stuff that all the
wise people from our generation from I'm
sorry from our civilization have always
believed across the generations
or to tell a kid that he's really the
opposite sex
and pump them full of poison and chop
him up which is child abuse we all know
the answer to that
but our present-day culture will not
tolerate the true answer
because a small handful of liberal
Elites
are working in concert with the
principalities and the powers of this
world to suppress the truth and to
promote evil it's exactly what Tucker
alluded to in his Heritage Foundation
speech
and that's the sort of thing you're not
allowed to say you're at least not
allowed to say it on mainstream cable TV
on the biggest name in news you're not
allowed to say that it's too true
we gotta pick one
what are we going to live according to
as Tucker made beautifully clear in his
speech we used to think of Politics as
you write your white paper and I write
my white paper and we have a
debate of ideas over which policy is
going to be conducive toward the end
that we all agree on
that's over
that's over now the question is
do kids get to be raised in a Christian
household period or are they going to be
raised by the throuple transing them
you pick
it's your it's your Society it's
supposed to be your Society it's
supposed to be a self-government is it
still I'm not sure speaking of sexual
politics there's new lawsuit against
Trump dropping
that's about that time of the week right
it's about that time of the week to have
a new lawsuit against Donald Trump
this one is from a lady named e Gene
Carroll
she is 79 or 80. it's actually unclear
what her age is I guess a lady never
tells uh she was a comedy writer and a
journalist some decades ago and she's
claiming that Trump raped her in 1995
or 1996.
details are a little blurry
as I guess they would be from 25 30
years ago
the year is a little blurry the
accusation is a little blurry the fact
that the accusation only came out some
20 30 years later that's kind of a
little bit weird
it's not credible
we've seen a lot of not credible
allegations against
politicians against regular ordinary
people in recent years I think you think
of the Duke lacrosse case
you think of the Jackie Rolling Stone
gang rape case about
was at the University of Virginia
you see
countless hoaxes
especially on campus adjudicated by
kangaroo courts I just gave a speech on
this topic not too long ago I forget
which school but it's up on the yaf
young America's Foundation YouTube
channel and then you've seen a lot of
these accusations against politicians
especially Brett Kavanaugh think about
the whole Kavanaugh confirmation with
some complete Looney Tune making an
absurd totally unsubstantiated
allegation against Kavanaugh and then
the libs cynically and opportunistically
tried to pretend that Brett Kavanaugh
one of the most milk toast men in the
American government was some kind of
serial rapist or something completely
absurd and here too obviously Trump has
lived a little bit of a looser life and
he's a well-known billionaire playboy
but if this were a credible case don't
you think it might have come up before
he were the Republican candidate for
president don't you think it might have
come up sometime earlier than 30 years
later
what is this show what it shows is
the libs will do absolutely anything
to stop this man from becoming president
again
they'll indeed him in New York over a
not even misdemeanor after the
expiration of the statute of limitations
because he made an in-kind contribution
to his own presidential campaign
they'll go after him in DC for I don't
know I don't even remember what they're
going after him in DC for first tell me
about the Insurrection or whatever then
in Georgia they're going to go after him
for calling the Secretary of State and
uh requesting some clarity on a an
election that had a lot of Shenanigans
in it
and now they're going to go after him
again for
allegedly raping a woman either in 95 or
96 or whatever who cares I don't know it
was a long time ago anyway can we send
him to jail yet
and what that tells me is
we shouldn't totally write Trump off
the fact that the libs would continue to
make absurd obviously false allegations
against him to try their best
to get this guy into an orange jumpsuit
tells me
that he despite all of his faults you
shouldn't count Trump out
if they hate him this much he's got to
be
at least somewhat over the Target now
speaking of who's running in 2024
Joe Biden is running for reelection
okay moving on no I'm joking well we can
talk about it for 30 seconds uh he
released a video he didn't do a big live
speech he doesn't have the energy or the
ability to articulate a vision for that
so he released some video he says he's
running again okay who cares uh bad news
for him is that there's an NBC News poll
found out that seventy percent seven
zero percent of Americans think that Joe
Biden should not run for re-election
which means that obviously the
Republicans don't think he should run
for re-election but also 51 percent of
Democrats don't think that he should run
for reelection this majority of
Democrats by my mathematical
calculations there only 26 percent of
Americans think that that Biden should
run
for president
now I think he does intend to run
I know a lot of people have said no he's
not going to run he's too old he knows
it's over he's just biting his time he
doesn't want to be a lame duck but then
he's going to drop out at the end maybe
he will I mean his his stamina has
obviously declined
so maybe something will happen and he
will have to drop out but I don't think
he intends to drop out
because Joe Biden has wanted to be
president since he was in the womb
and Joe Biden doesn't like the people in
his party what do you think you think
Joe Biden is just going to step down the
thing he's wanted his whole life that
he's run for since the 1980s you think
he's just going to give it up so what so
he can clear the way for Kamala Harris
he hates Kamala Harris he's going to
clear the way for the woman who called
him a racist a national television that
was her entire presidential campaign I
don't think so
you think Biden is going to step down so
he clears the way for mayor Pete the
only guy in America who could screw up
being Transportation secretary is one of
the easiest jobs in the government he
somehow manages to screw it up probably
because he didn't show up because he was
chest feeding for months
yeah I don't know I don't think he's
going to do that you think that Biden's
gonna step down to clear the way for
governor Bateman American Psycho Gavin
Newsom so that Gavin Newsom can take the
thing at a much younger age that Biden's
been working for his whole life I don't
think so
why would Biden do it what's the guy yes
he's diminished
what's the guy got to gain what's the
guy got to lose
this is it it doesn't get any better
than this for Joe Biden so he's running
again okay
okay that's fine he better keep up his
stamina when you want to keep up your
stamina get really good nutrition you
got to check out good ranchers right now
go to goodranchors.com use promo code at
Knowles if you have not changed the way
you buy meat yet you really need to do
you know what I had for dinner last
night
give you one guess I had good ranchers I
had a delicious good Rancher steak it
was juicy it was it's just it is the
finest quality beef that I have in my I
have it not every day but
a great many days I just adore good
ranchers I got three reasons for you one
they give you free bacon for a year
that's a pound and a half of bacon in
every box 240 value number two good
ranchers offers a price lock guarantee
meaning that when you subscribe your
price does not change for the length of
your subscription meat is expected to go
up four and a half percent in the coming
year so this could be a huge savings for
you and your family number three good
ranchers meat is unlike any other
all natural Burgers USDA prime steaks
better than organic chicken will change
your standard for great meat it's I'm a
real stickler when it comes to my meat
quality it's magnificent go to
goodranches.com use promo code nulls for
20 bucks off your box
free bacon great meat a secure price and
a bonus 20 off today promo code Knolls
at goodranters.com goodranchers.com
American Meat delivered you know it
seems as though fewer and fewer of us
are on the same page when it comes to
the fundamentals this is obviously a
huge problem when it comes to our
relationship to each other and our
relationship to God but this is not a
new phenomenon the consequences of this
disunity date back all the way to the
time of Moses just listen to what Jordan
Peterson has to say about it in the 16th
episode of Exodus there's an irony here
that
for all the insistence upon
equality
the very foundation for that equality in
Western culture i the idea that human
beings are made in the Imago day in the
image of God has been lost of course so
it's almost as if because of the erosion
of this Foundation
the drive for equality is stressed all
the more that's that's exactly what
needs you that's exactly what nature
claimed would happen when he wrote well
when he's particularly in Beyond Good
and Evil he said that was that was
inevitable that would be an inevitable
consequence one of my main conclusions
from this episode is that I need a cool
accent so I'll be working on that you
should work on watching the show Jordan
is joined by a round table of big
thinkers from different backgrounds who
explore a seminal book of our whole
civilization and of course of the Bible
it is Thoroughly engrossing stuff we are
heading into the conclusion of Exodus
which is exclusively for daily wire Plus
members if you haven't seen it start at
the beginning because it is well worth
your time join now at dailywire.com
subscribe to watch Exodus
okay Biden's gonna run who's running for
the Republicans well it certainly would
seem as though Ron DeSantis is running
for president he's really ramped up the
campaigning here and a Santa says a new
line of attack against Donald Trump it's
probably his most effective line of
attack yet
leaders take the bull by the horns and
make the decisions for themselves they
don't subcontract out their leadership
to health bureaucrats like Dr fauci
shade cast burn Sizzle this is a pretty
good line of attack it's the best line
of attack against Trump I think that
there is
you could go after Trump on this policy
or that policy but I think the most
effective one will be to say Trump gave
the country away during covid now the
response to that is would anybody at the
federal level
being told that if you don't follow
these recommendations millions and
millions of Americans are going to die
and it's going to be your fault they're
going to send you to the Hague probably
would they have done anything different
I don't know Ronda santis can make a
fairly credible case that he would have
done something different because
although he was cautious about covet in
those initial months he reopened Florida
very quickly and then all the businesses
and all the events and all of social
life just went down to Florida and so
people got to see in real time that
things were different uh certainly the
best line of attack yet now DeSantis is
trying to be clear though
that he is not yet
a candidate Governor I'll show you
falling behind uh Trump any thoughts on
that I'm not I'm not a candidate so
we'll see if if and when that changes
he says uh I'm not a candidate yet buddy
uh now the reason that the I'm not a
candidate yet line is not totally
persuasive is that Governor DeSantis
made these comments from Japan and as
you know Florida doesn't have a
a ton of foreign negotiations usually
with
other nations and it doesn't have a ton
to do with Japan but Governor DeSantis
is using some economic plan in Florida
as an excuse to go around and do a
little bit of a world tour this is
something that presidential candidates
have done for a very long time and so
it's it's natural that he would be asked
on the campaign Trail
so what do you think about the polls you
know Trump is still pretty strong in the
polls you're falling behind a little bit
and DeSantis I I think is just trying to
make a little joke here which is well
just wait until I kick off my campaign
uh but but it's difficult to do that
with a straight face of course when
you're a an American governor and you're
in some foreign country right right
before you're expected to announce your
presidential campaign
now speaking of those polls Trump
seeing a threat from DeSantis and maybe
even from other people we'll get to that
in just one second is saying that he
might not
participate in a Republican primary
debate
what Trump has said is
I see that everybody's talking about the
Republican debates but nobody got my
approval or the approval of the Trump
campaign before announcing them
when you're leading by seemingly
insurmountable numbers and you have
hostile networks with angry Trump and
Maga hating anchors asking that
questions
why subject yourself to being libled and
abused
also the second debate is being held at
the Reagan Library the chairman of which
is amazingly Fred Ryan publisher of the
Washington Post no
so he starts out skeptical of debates by
the end he says now we're not doing that
what is he doing here is he really
saying that he won't debate well if he's
high up enough in the polls I guess he
could try to get out of it and he is
very high in the polls right now but is
he High Enough
especially this early on that he doesn't
have to debate I doubt it
I suspect this is more of a bluff a
little bit of a threat to try to gain
some leverage if it is as president
Trump is describing it that he's had
really no say in how these debates will
take place then yeah he has every right
to say listen folks
you guys can set whatever debates you
want but I'm the big dog in the race
here and so you're gonna have to deal
with me and we're gonna need to make
sure this isn't totally stacked against
Trump that said he should debate
in 2016 that was his greatest strength
he he didn't do great in the debates in
2020 in part because incumbents usually
lose the first debate and then with all
the coveted craziness uh and all of the
upending of the election rules Trump
didn't really have a chance to to win it
back to fight back in a way that say
Reagan did but but Trump was great in
the debates in 2016. he absolutely
destroyed the other candidates on the
stage so I think it's to his Advantage
especially because he's
among the top tier candidates right now
he is the most Charming whether you like
him or not he's the most Charming he's
the most show busy he's the most
relatable on a stage so I think he
should go for it but but
he'll he'll try to throw his weight
around as much as he can to make sure
that the debates aren't totally hostile
to him now
now I have a theory
I told you that there were other threats
to Trump and I have a theory and I know
you're going to laugh at me so I if
you're driving I want you to pull over I
don't want to be responsible for any car
crashes
I think there was a dark horse candidate
I have a theory
that no it's not well DeSantis is not a
dark horse candidate he's one of the top
two candidates right now and it's not
Pompeo he's not running it's not Cruz
he's not running it's not I don't think
it's Mike Pence I don't think it's Nikki
Haley necessarily even she is running I
don't think it's
Vivek the vague's doing great stuff but
the the secret Dark Horse candidate that
nobody's talking about
Chris Christie I know you're laughing
you say Michael there's no way we're
going to see a chrysosons I think we
might be on the cusp of a chrysosons
hear me out
Chris Christie
is the governor was the governor of New
Jersey very successful two-term governor
in New Jersey he was talked about as a
potential presidential candidate far
back as 2012.
Chris Christie being a Northeastern
Governor is more liberal Centrist
moderate whatever you want to say then a
lot of people in The Party The
Establishment loves that
but Chris Christie being from New Jersey
is extremely obnoxious
and pretty funny and he's got a kind of
gruff tough sense of humor
which is
something that appeals to the base it
appeals to me it appeals to a lot of
people it's one of Trump's great
strengths is he's got that New York
fighting Sensibility
so in Chris Christie
you get a candidate who is palatable to
The Establishment much more so than a
trump
but has the sizzle and the fight that
appeals to more rock ribbed bloodthirsty
Types on the right which the other
non-trump candidates don't really have
quite as much don't forget you're I know
you're still laughing at me okay but I'm
just I want to remind you
Chris Christie though he's probably
polling at zero percent right now
he's really great on debate stage do you
remember what he did to Marco Rubio
let's dispel with this fiction that
Barack Obama doesn't know what he's
doing he knows exactly what he's doing
he is trying to change this country he
wants America to become more like the
rest of the world we don't want to be
like the rest of the world we want to be
the United States of America and when
I'm elected president this will become
once again the single greatest nation in
the history of the world not the
disaster Barack Obama has imposed upon
us you see everybody I want the people
at home to think about this that's what
Washington DC does the drive-by shot at
the beginning with Incorrect and
incomplete information and then the
memorized 25 second speech that is
exactly what his advisors gave him
see see Marco Marco the thing is this
when you're president United States when
you're a governor of a state the
memorized 30-second speech where you
talk about how great America is at the
end of it doesn't solve one problem for
one person they expect you to plow the
snow they expect you to get the schools
open this notion that Barack Obama
doesn't know what he's doing is just not
there it is with the memorized 25-second
speech there it is I'm not saying Chris
Christie should be the nominee obviously
far from it
what I am I'm not saying he's going to
be the nominee I'm not saying he's even
going to ever pull that high
but I would not be surprised if Chris
Christie had
a moment okay I'm telling you if if
Chris Christie ever does run and he's
signaling that he will run
and if Chris Christie pops up on any of
the betting sites I'll probably put a
little bit of money on Chris Christie
weirder things have happened in
presidential races and for the people
right now who believe that this race
forget even Chris Christie for a second
if you believe that this race is just
totally set in stone you haven't paid
attention to
2016 2012 2008 2000
96 92. you haven't
you haven't paid a 10 crazier things
have happened even then
the chrysosons
now speaking of candidates who were also
something of a Dark Dark Horse
candidates though in this case a
candidate who is much better liked and
uh probably
getting uh much more support right now
would be my friend the vague ramaswamy
and Vivek
it just has a great take not on the
state of the race everyone's always
talking about the horse races and the
numbers and everything the bank just
came out with a great point on why the
libs are so opposed to nuclear energy
well the first thing that's going on is
that actually it has nothing to do with
the climate it has to do with
an anti-growth agenda in the United
States itself an agenda that says that
part of the problem
is that we should live with less we
should learn to live more simple
Lifestyles that we should learn to
apologize for our modern way of life and
our success in America so the rest of
the world can catch up and nuclear
energy throws a wrench into that plan
because if you adopt nuclear energy in
America you might actually
God forbid solve their own climate
disaster crisis their energy clean
energy crisis
and yet do it in a way that still allows
GDP growth to remain on a steep slope In
America which would solve which would
prevent them from addressing the deeper
problem they want to address which is
their agenda of global Equity that's
what this is about it is about making
the West an American particular
apologize for its sins of GDP growth in
the past by applying shackles then to
Future growth to allow places like China
on the other side of the world to catch
up
it's a really smart take from Vivek as
as many of the Vex takes are as very
very smart one because this is something
that always has puzzled a lot of
conservatives they say hold on you
environmentalists okay you think that
gasoline and oil are bad for the
environment we could have a debate about
that but okay fine and you think coal is
bad for the environment okay I guess I
kind of get it but
then why are you guys totally opposed to
the only
clean energy source
that could power our whole country and
is relatively safe and is relatively
extremely clean and is relatively
extremely efficient why are you opposed
to nuclear
if you want to solve this environmental
problem and Vivek points out he says
there the last part is the key
if they want us but they don't want to
solve the environmental problem
because if they solve the environmental
problem then they no longer that which
real or imagined okay I'm not saying
that we're on the brink of an
environmental catastrophe far from it
but they say that and they don't want to
fix that because they need to be on the
brink of catastrophe in order to justify
the rest of their program we need to be
on the brink of Armageddon the world has
to be about to end in 12 years it's
always 12 more years I don't know every
year it just gets pushed back a year but
it's always about five to ten to 12
years
the world is going to end if you don't
give us all your money give us all the
political power let us totally upend the
political economy let us upend your diet
let us upend the way that you drive and
commute and live
that's why that the nuclear The
anti-nuclear Stance from the left is the
giveaway that none of this is about
solving any supposed environmental
catastrophe on the horizon
the catastrophe is there to serve the
broader political purpose of reordering
society
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Lewis Henson who says how about we make
a documentary about Booker T Washington
played by Michael Knowles it's a great
idea and it's a better idea even than
you know because not many people know
that Booker T Washington's middle name
the T stands for Taliaferro which is an
Italian name means iron cutter
now it was Booker of Italian descent I
don't think so he is half white but I
don't think the his father whom he
didn't own about whom we know nothing I
don't
think he was of the
mezzojorno you know somebody tells me he
wasn't Italian but he did take the name
Taliaferro and so there you go so I have
a good argument for the casting director
certainly a better argument than than
the nucleopatra movie as for its casting
decisions
now
speaking of women
speaking of women in the media moving
from Cleopatra onto the London Marathon
one of the women running in the women's
section of the London Marathon
is someone named Glenn who for the last
two years has gone by glenique
Glenn Frank
who just gave an interview to the Press
on what
his performance in the London Marathon
means for girl power
[Music]
New York I was there and then this year
in Chicago I've got in 2024 will be the
number six and then that's the week
before London so a week rest but tip
girl power
it's
you have to laugh a little bit because
you the other choice would be to cry
if this news reporter had interviewed
any actual woman do you think the woman
would have ended her interview by saying
girl power
yeah
yeah you know well listen here John and
George always love to talk about Bill
power that's the only British accent I
can really do is Paul McCartney No they
wouldn't have
they wouldn't feel the need to call
attention
to the fact that they are women because
they know that they're women and
everyone knows that they're women okay
we can move on
the transgender movement
insists upon this this is why they wear
the most ridiculous clothing this is why
they're constantly talking about
Womanhood this is why they're constantly
harping on their pronouns and how
wonderful it is to be a woman this is
why Dylan Mulvaney has made his entire
now quite lucrative career on what what
it is to be a woman every single day
this isn't just about some people with
some quirky sexual ideas trying to pass
and live their own lives in society it's
never been about that
it's always about forcing this
Preposterous ideology down everybody's
throat
every single public expression of
transgenderism amounts to this guy's
interview
yeah girl power yeah I'm a woman 365th
day of being a woman I'm a woman I'm she
oh gosh being a woman it's so hard we
got to go out shopping buy dresses oh I
just love being a woman I'm a woman look
at me look at me and
they do this
because they want you to lie
they want it to be impossible for you to
ignore or politely sort of Turn Your
Eyes away from their
absurdity
you have to engage with it
and you have to go along with it and you
have to assent to it you have to affirm
it you have to lie
you have to lie
if we
establish transgenderism in public life
you will have to lie that is the point
there's no getting away there's no Live
and Let Live it was never about Live and
Let Live speaking of living and dying
do you know about the proxy war that
we're engaged in in Sudan probably not
it hasn't made a lot of news
there's a civil war right now in Sudan
and the only reason you may have
potentially heard about this is because
news reports are out that one faction of
the Sudanese Civil War has now occupied
a biological lab and the World Health
Organization is warning that a quote
extremely extremely dangerous situation
is threatening Public Health after the
fighters in central Sudan occupied a
laboratory carrying samples of deadly
diseases including polio including
cholera
a who representative there Nima Syed
Abid says there is a huge biological
risk associated with the occupation of
the Central Public Health lab by one of
the fighting parties
so what's this Civil War in Sudan all
about the Civil War in Sudan obviously
has a domestic component to it but
increasingly it's being viewed and you
can you can read about it Washington
examiner you read about it elsewhere it
is being viewed as a proxy war between
the United States and Russia because the
factions the the two factions in Sudan
are being backed alternately by the
United States role and and by Russia
what does this mean for us
it means that
when we engage in diplomacy
and when we engage in war and when we
escalate war and when we recklessly
escalate War as the Biden Administration
has done in Ukraine
it's very difficult to contain that war
it's very difficult to
predict exactly what's going to happen
there were a lot of people
these days mostly in the liberal
establishment
previously you heard this kind of
rhetoric from the neoconservatives who I
guess are kind of in the liberal
establishment too but they're a little
bit distinct so who were so boastful
so any of these wars around the world we
could go in we'd clobber the enemy in
two seconds oh yeah the whole War it'll
take two weeks
and then we'll just move on
there we go American might is exercised
America and hegemony is preserved we'll
come home
liberators it'll take two seconds all of
our enemies will back down we'll be out
of there you won't even know we went
and that just isn't how it has turned
out it's not how it turned out in Iraq
it's not how it turned out in
Afghanistan it's not how it turned out
in Libya it's not how it turned out in
Ukraine and in the Ukraine war it's the
U.S fighting a proxy war with Russia in
Ukraine which is pretty dangerous when
you have the global superpower fighting
a war a hot War according to Russian
ministers uh with a former superpower
that has nuclear weapons with whom we
fought a cold war for the last half of
the 20th century but then you think oh
it's okay we'll just contain it to
to Ukraine until oh look now there's a
proxy conflict breaking out in Sudan and
oh look while the U.S is mired in this
conflict it looks as though China is
beginning to aggress in the South China
Sea in Taiwan and oh look
circumstances spin out of control before
our genius Master of the Universe ruling
class knows what hit them
world wars have started for a lot less
than this and they've started under the
leadership of much more serious
Statesmen than this
and that's going to be an important
question
in the 2024 race not just
are men and women different not just are
we going to not kill the babies not just
are we going to take care of immigration
not just are we going to revive the
economy also who do you trust to wage a
World War because increasingly we appear
to be spinning toward such a thing
seeing a lot of violence around here
there's just one example of this on the
domestic front a Utah state senator his
home was just attacked by a transgender
identifying vandal
and the state senator State Senator Mike
Kennedy said his home was vandalized he
posted a photo with the words fash
because the the libs and especially the
trans activists they call anyone who is
in any way Tethered to reality they call
they call us fascists and says these
bash back
was spray painted on a red house these
trainees bash back get it say these
trans activists are going to get violent
oh oh you're the ones who will oh yeah
we haven't seen any violence from the
pro-transgenderism political activists
yeah we don't know we haven't seen that
anywhere you're right
I don't see that every time I go to a
college campus just about we haven't
seen that in in much more aggressive and
horrific ways just in the last month no
no these these pro-trans activists we
bash back
as I have said before
it's always the ones you most expect
and when one's ideology is premised on
irrationality and denying reality and
denying the truth and purely imposing
one's will untethered from intellect
well you can probably expect irrational
behavior let's walk Wednesday speaking
of irrational Behavior so we've got two
woke tick tocks I think on the
transgender issue that Mr Davies wants
me to see
the show continues now daily wire.com
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign